- I was always a firm
believer of whatever gift
that you have culturally,
you should be able
to make a life out of it.
Right now, I'm working on dog
collars, beaded dog collars.
I haven't made money
since March. So I got to
figure out other ways to take
care of myself and my family.
So what better way to do it
then to use your own culture?
- [Reporter] As the COVID-19
pandemic stretches into
a second year, New Orleans,
a city hit hard early on
in the pandemic and whose
economy is dependent on tourism
is trying to keep case
numbers down while also
figuring out what tourism
looks like in 2021.
To better understand how the
city's economic landscape is
impacting those whose
livelihoods are connected
to the tourism industry,
I spoke to a few people
to find out how they're
surviving financially,
and what's at stake for their businesses
and their communities.
- How important is tourism
to the New Orleans economy?
- Tourism is our major economic driver.
Mardi Gras is a big, big deal.
There is a tremendous amount
of tax revenue generated
so we are certainly missing that.
- [Reporter] The destination
marketing organization
in the city says the tourism
industry was down 70%
in 2020 compared to 2019.
But Jay Banks, a city
council member says safety
is the priority over finances.
- I clearly understand
the economics of this, but
I'm also clearly understanding
the health concerns of it.
And while I would like to be able to say
that we can do everything
we do and keep people safe,
unfortunately we can't.
(Upbeat jazz music)
- Before the pandemic,
how many nights a week
were you playing?
- I was playing like two
or three clubs a week
before the pandemic.
- [Reporter] Renard Henry who
was born and raised in Tremé,
a historically black
neighborhood with deep-rooted
musical traditions comes from
an important musical family
in new Orleans.
- [Renard] Justin Jones is my grandfather
and I have an uncle
Benny, he's the leader of
the Tremé Brass Band. And I
have my brother Corey Henry.
(Upbeat jazz music)
- [Reporter] Henry says the
gigs he's able to get now
pay less than before the pandemic.
Recently, he performed with
Tremé Brass Band outside DBA,
a popular Frenchman Street
club that he used to
play inside of.
- We're playing in the
DBA, we would average
maybe like $200, $250
with some tips, you know.
But nowadays we're playing outside.
We're roughing it up, scrambling
like a little $40, $50.
- [Reporter] Henry has
been able to find work
through a Mardi Gras crew
that has hired artists
and musicians as couriers,
house float designers, and more.
It's just one example of how
the city has come together
to help those who have taken
the biggest financial hit.
(exciting music)
- Hey, guys! How you doing?
- [Reporter] For Alexis
Graber, better known as
Trixie Minx, The Burlesque
Queen of New Orleans,
her business, Trixie Minx
Productions was doing well
prior to the pandemic.
- That first quarter of
2020 was actually like
our highest grossing quarter yet to date.
And we went from that to literally,
it wasn't exactly zero, but like, I cried.
- [Reporter] And almost
a year into the pandemic,
she's struggling to keep
her business afloat,
while also keeping her
employees working safely.
- I've tried everything.
I've done everything from
in-person shows to virtual
shows to zoom performances.
- [Reporter] In October, she
launched a weekly virtual show
at DBA on Frenchmen Street.
- All those shows went so
smoothly, but the problem was is
that we didn't make money. And
if anything, we lost money.
And that quarter, I say
this a lot, it felt like
a sucker punch and a knife twist
and a kick while you were down.
- [Reporter] After a reset,
she scaled back the shows
at DBA to once a month.
- I was super excited
about this, honestly.
Thank you guys for making my weekend.
The hardest choice I had
to make was realizing we
had to do less, to be
able to save the business.
And it seems counterintuitive,
but in doing shows,
doing them safely, and
doing them regularly
actually lost the company more money.
- Well, this is a live music
street first and foremost.
That's what keeps it going.
And unless we all open,
it doesn't really do much good.
- [Reporter] Another
business owner who found that
being open was actually
causing her to lose more money,
is Sophie Lee Lowry, the
owner of Three Muses,
a restaurant and jazz
club on Frenchman Street.
- A regular Friday night,
you can't even get a table.
- Mm hm.
- Or sit at the bar.
- [Reporter] But the pandemic
forced the restaurant
to close down in March
until they were able to
get a PPP grant.
- I had used my savings, I
borrowed money from family,
exhausted every avenue I had until finally
the money came in.
- [Reporter] She tried to
reopen for takeout and delivery,
but without the street's
regular foot traffic,
she found it wasn't sustainable.
- Can you talk a little bit about how much
you're still paying to
keep this place dormant?
- Back in March, April, May,
not only did we have the rent
and utilities, we still
had purveyors that we owed.
So our income stopped March 15th,
but our bills kept coming in.
It was somewhere around $30,000 a month,
just operating costs on
a shuttered business.
Thankfully, that's gone
down as our bills were paid.
So now I would say it's around $15,000.
- A month?
- A month, for a closed business. Yes.
- With zero revenue coming
in to balance it out.
- With zero revenue.
(laughing).
Right.
- [Reporter] Her application
for a second round of PPP
was denied, but she's reapplied
with additional documentation
and she's holding off
on reopening until she gets funding
and the COVID-19 outlook improves.
(lively drum music)
- [Singer] Now roll with it!
- [Reporter] For many in New Orleans,
the pandemic isn't just
a threat to their health
or their bank accounts.
It's also a threat to
their cultural traditions.
- You know, culture doesn't
get preserved for free.
- [Reporter] Shaka Zulu is the Big Chief
of the Golden Feather Hunters,
a masking Indian tribe
in New Orleans. He has
a few businesses related
to his culture, like a
gallery, a stage performance,
and a feather supply
company. On the weekends,
he teaches an African stilt
dancing class in his community.
- My life is, you know,
not just a cultural keeper.
This is what I do for a living.
- [Reporter] The pandemic
ground has worked to a halt,
but for Zulu, the questions
are bigger than when
he will be able to resume those projects.
- I think this pandemic
exposed what's been going
on for since the beginning.
- [Reporter] He says the
pandemic has highlighted
long-term inequality. How
dollars brought into New Orleans
by tourists don't always
find their way back
to the culture bearers who attract many
of those visitors to the city.
- How come it's always
about us, but when it
comes to economics, it's without us?
(lively drum music)
The pandemic may possibly
bring attention to that,
because for once, everybody
is shut down, you know.
Nobody is open. So now, what's going
to bring the tourism back?
(music ends)
- That's it! Party over.
- Yeah!
(applause)